Russland verfeuert an einem einzigen Tag
so viel Artilleriemunition wie die
europäische Rüstungsindustrie in einem
ganzen Monat produziert deshalb soll
diese nun hochgefahren werden so lautet
eine der Erkenntnisse auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz die gestern mit
einem Appell zu Ende gingen
wir dürfen keine Zeit verlieren bei der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat der
Außenbeauftragte der Europäischen Union
den Vorschlag gemacht dass wir auch die
munitionsbeschaffung dass wir das auf
europäischer Ebene machen damit wir der
Ukraine schnell helfen können und es
wäre ganz wichtig dass jetzt hier sofort
operiert wird für Überraschung sorgte
eine von Chinas Chefdiplomat Wii
angekündigte Friedensinitiative für den
Ukraine Krieg China hätte gegenüber
Russland militärisch und wirtschaftlich
geeignete Druckmittel in der Hand sagen
Experten wir wissen dass das russische
Militär Reifen Halbleiter und
chemische Grundkomponenten bekommt die
für die Herstellung von Munition wichtig
sind aber ob man die auch wirklich
einsetzt um Druck auszuüben da habe ich
große Zweifel China werde einen eigenen
Plan vorlegen und zwar die chinesische
Position zur politischen Beilegung der
ukraine-krise versprach Wang Lee wie das
konkret ausfällt darauf muss man warten
es gibt keine konkreten Details es gibt
nur den Hinweis dass man sich da zurück
beziehen möchte auf Punkte der Parteien
Staatschef sieht imping schon gemacht
haben und das verspricht jetzt erstmal
keine Lösung dieses Konfliktes China sei
in diesem Konflikt nicht neutral Schuld
an dem Ukraine Krieg sei die NATO allen
voran die USA so dass chinesische
narrativ Moskau sind wichtiger Partner
für Peking da geht es um gemeinsame
Interessen die gegen den Westen gegen
die USA auch mit Blick auf die Zukunft
der globalen Ordnung durchgesetzt werden
sollen die Kluft zwischen den
Supermächten China und USA sie wurde
nach dem wohl wichtigsten treffen auf
der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
deutlich ein Gespräch zwischen dem
US-Außenminister und dem chinesischen
Chef Diplomaten unter Ausschluss der
Öffentlichkeit blinken spricht direkt
danach im US-Fernsehen eine Warnung aus
wir haben besorgniserregende
Informationen dass China Russland mit
Waffen unterstützen will ich habe
klargestellt dass das ernste
Konsequenzen für unser Verhältnis haben
würde heute beraten die EU-Außenminister
in Brüssel über das zehnte
Sanktionspaket gegenüber Russland es
umfasst exportverbote von elektronischen
Bauteilen für Drohnen und Flugzeuge ziel
ist es die russische Kriegsmaschine die
technologisch auszuhebeln
schalten wir zunächst unserer
Korrespondentin in Brüssel Isabel
Schäfers guten Morgen hier aus Berlin
wir haben es also gerade gehört die
EU-Außenminister beraten heute über
weitere Russland Sanktionen und
zusätzliche Militärhilfe für die Ukraine
was ist da genau geplant
ja also auf jeden Fall liegt der Fokus
hier eindeutig bei der Ukraine heute bei
dem EU-Außenminister treffen zumal auch
der ukrainische Außenminister Kollege
hier dabei sein wird in Brüssel und der
wird wohl die Forderung seines Landes
nach mehr Waffen nach Kampfjets und auch
nach Munition noch mal wiederholen und
darüber wird dann auch hier wohl
diskutiert werden wie die EU
möglicherweise jetzt gemeinsam Munition
einkaufen kann da gibt es eben die Idee
dass wir bei den Impfstoffen damals zu
machen dass die Kommission gemeinsam
zentral Großaufträge an die
Rüstungsindustrie vergibt und die
Mitgliedstaaten das Geld dafür geben wie
erfolgreich das damals bei den
Impfstoffen war dazu gibt's
unterschiedliche Meinungen aber
zumindest scheinen die meisten hier
erstmal offen zu sein dass jetzt in
Bezug auf die Munition zu diskutieren
und dann gibt es das zehnte
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland was
diskutiert wird da geht es etwa um die
Listung weiterer Personen die russischen
Propagandisten und auch die
Sanktionierung von technologischen
Gütern die auch für militärische Zwecke
eingesetzt werden könnten eine zentrale
Frage dabei jetzt bei diesem Paket ist
aber wie man bisher bestehende
Schlupflöcher schließen kann weil
Russland wohl bisher viele der
Sanktionen umgeht über Drittstaaten und
das Ziel bei diesem 10 Sanktionspaket
ist eindeutig dass bis zum Ende der
Woche also bis zu diesem
symbolträchtigen jahrestag des
russischen Angriffs dann auch endlich zu
verabschieden Isabel Schäfers war das
mit Informationen aus Brüssel vielen
Dank für die Einordnung und von Brüssel
zurück jetzt nach Berlin Michael Roth
der Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses von der SPD ist bei uns im
schönen guten Morgen guten Morgen Frau
Waldenfels sie waren natürlich mit dabei
in München bei der Sicherheitskonferenz
welche Bilanz ziehen sie gab es für sie
so etwas wie die eine Kernbotschaft
dass die demokratischen Staaten der Welt
aber auch weit darüber hinaus wir
geschlossen und solidarisch an der Seite
der Ukraine stehen das ist wichtig wer
hätte das für möglich gehalten wenn wir
uns die Situation vor fast einem Jahr
anschauen niemand hat damit gerechnet
dass die Ukraine diesen furchtbaren
Angriffskrieg Russlands zu überstehen
vermag und jetzt gibt es nach wie vor
eine realistische Chance dass die
Ukraine gewinnen kann als freies
demokratisches souveränes Land aber
dafür muss sie auch weiterhin
bestmöglich ausgestattet und unterstützt
werden und in dem Punkt hatte
Bundeskanzler Scholz da ja
bekanntermaßen lange gezögert hat
schwere Waffen zu liefern seine Meinung
geändert und ermuntert ja man kann fast
sagen drängt dazu andere Partner
mittlerweile mitzuziehen und auch Panzer
zu schicken und plötzlich steht
Deutschland was Europa angeht an der
Spitze was die Waffenlieferungen angeht
auch wenn er noch nicht so viel Tempo
drin ist vielleicht nötig ist Olaf
Scholz momentan getriebener oder Treiber
er ist Treiber im Team mit anderen und
Deutschland ist schon lange in Europa
auf Platz eins neben den Vereinigten
Königreich ich bin nicht glücklich mit
der Debatte wir haben spätestens seit
September die Diskussion über eine
europäische Allianz für Leopard also für
kampfpanzerlieferungen dass einige sich
nach wie vor sehr schwer tun gleichwohl
es noch vor Wochen klare Ankündigungen
gegeben hat diese Allianz beizutreten
finde ich nicht hilfreich aber wir
sollten das hinter den Kulissen
diskutieren so wie das der Kanzler wie
das die Außenministerin übrigens auch
tut damit noch möglichst viele Staaten
die über diese Leopards verfügen dann
auch
die Ukraine unterstützen können und dann
gibt es ja auch noch die Frage nach dem
Flugzeugen
auch da sehe ich jetzt
keine roten Linien aber wir sollten uns
auf das konzentrieren was am
dringendsten ist und während wir jetzt
fast ein Jahr lang über immer neue
Waffensysteme gesprochen haben geht es
jetzt darum dass wir unsere
Unterstützung verstetigen und dabei
spielt die Munition eine ganz
entscheidende Rolle es geht auch um
Instandsetzung um Reparatur und da
Bedarf ist enger Abstimmung mit der
Industrie da gibt es ja jetzt auch heute
in Brüssel das wurde eben auch gesagt
Diskussionen wie man das beschleunigen
kann denn wir können müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass dieser Krieg noch einige
Zeit dauert Frankreichs Präsident macron
sagt es sei noch nicht die Stunde die
ist des Dialogs wann ist die gekommen
wenn Russland dazu bereit ist es gehört
ja zu der perfiden Propaganda Russlands
den Eindruck zu erwecken als sei der
Westen als sei die Ukraine nicht bereit
zu verhandeln am Ende liegt es an
Russland weil es nach wie vor darauf
besteht die Ukraine das russische Volk
zu vernichten die Regierung aus dem Amt
zu nehmen
es gibt keine Bereitschaft zu
ernsthaften Diskussionen insofern müssen
wir uns auf Prinzipien verständigen wie
beispielsweise die Wahrung der
territorialen Integrität der Ukraine und
für diplomatische Bemühungen wenn sie
denn gepaart sind mit Wehrhaftigkeit und
mit Abschreckung ist es nie zu spät und
nie zu früh dazu hat China jetzt ein
Vorstoß gewagt und gesagt sie planten
möglicherweise eine Friedensinitiative
was halten Sie davon bin gespannt China
behauptet ja immer ein neutraler Staat
zu sein gegenüber Russland das stimmt
natürlich nicht
China unterstützt militärisch politisch
wissenschaftlich die
Russische Föderation aber wenn es einen
ein Bekenntnis Chinas gibt zum
internationalen Völkerrecht zum
humanitären Völkerrecht dann sollten wir
das ernsthaft prüfen aber was nicht geht
ist eine solche Friedenslösung nur mit
Russland zu besprechen und nicht auch
mit der Ukraine nochmal zu China die USA
befürchten china könnte Waffen am
Russland liefern was würde das bedeuten
na erst einmal haben wir jetzt schon
eine sehr schmerzhafte Situation für die
Ukraine das sogenannte dual-news-güter
aus China nach Russland geliefert werden
durch Güter sind Güter die man auch für
militärische Zwecke einsetzen kann und
ich kann nur hoffen dass China diese
rote Linie nicht übersteigen wird am
Ende ist es ja unter anderem auch das
Verdienst des Bundeskanzlers gewesen
auch noch mal zumindestens ein klares
Signal aus Peking zu erzielen das
Russland niemals mit dem ein bereits von
Atomwaffen drohen darf oder sogar
einsetzen kann Michael Roth von der SPD
der Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses war das vielen Dank für das
Gespräch danke Ihnen